[Music]
really good now what's his name i can't
remember his name why do i care
why do i care clap
happy thursday everyone what a magical
show we have planned for you and that's
because it's time once again for
everything is racist
so just the other day i was sending a
text to a close friend of mine i'm lying
i'm making up an antidote to kick off
this monologue i don't have any close
friends other than my goldfish abe
and even he hates me
but while sending the text i wanted to
end it with the right emoji a thumbs up
if you will the problem is i'm white i
know spoiler but usually i just use the
emoji that pops up the default thumbs up
it's kind of yellow what's called these
days simpsons yellow now except for that
time i caught scurvy from kat i'm not
cartoon yellow i'm white really white so
white in fact that i wear khakis to bed
which means when i'm choosing the
default thumbs up which is canary yellow
aren't i cloaking my whiteness aren't i
hiding my privilege
you might even call it appropriating
i'm white using a yellow thumb
so the question plagued me i couldn't
sleep i couldn't eat i could barely look
at myself in the mirror which could have
been fatal if i were jesse waters
all this time as a white man i was
identifying as a simpson and not even a
hot one like ashley or oj
well thank god for npr because they
tackled this dilemma for me yes in
between fun drives and profiles of trans
sheep they published an article on which
skin color emoji should you use
the reply which they supplied the answer
is more complex than you think and
that's because depending on your race
they could denote white privilege
especially if you use the yellow thumbs
up emoji that means if you're white
that you're ignorant of your own
advantage in life like being able to
choose any emoji you want some people
don't have that privilege like some
minorities and also careless woodshop
teachers
by the way even though i am white my
thumb identifies as a pinky
now the article is so important that it
actually took three authors to put put
it together even my employees didn't
laugh
that's two more authors than it took to
write war and peace and 20 less than it
took to write how i saved the world
their beef that many people of color are
exhausted that's the word they used
they're exhausted of having to grapple
with their emoji issues while white
people just ignore it subconsciously and
even though we assume the yellow thumbs
up is neutral some academics i.e freaks
argue that when you make that choice
you're opting out of your commitment to
awareness
which sounds interesting
oh who am i kidding it's not interesting
at all i'm just sick and tired of
talking about coveted in crime all the
time and i'm out of poop jokes since i
started that juice cleanse
but covet and crime are big problems and
it would be great if this emoji thing
were so big an issue we could lead off
the show with it how awesome would your
life be if all you had to deal with is
being exhausted by emoji privilege
hey joe you look really down you feeling
okay yeah i'm fine but i was up until
four this morning trying to decide how
to sign off on a text
so you want to talk about actual
privilege the most privilegy thing is
the existence of this article
imagine the sheer lack of problems you
have that would allow you to spend all
this time and effort wondering if your
emoji might be racist i have an inkling
that this is not a concern for parents
of screaming kids it's not a concern for
anyone who truly works for a living it's
not a concern for anyone who has a sick
relative not a concern for any victim of
crime this kind of could certainly exist
in people with woke privilege
academics people who really don't have
to do anything but write silly little
articles to show how smart they are
but these are pointless people lucky to
be alive in a really easy time to be
alive it's america 2022 netflix uber
pornhub pot life's a breeze for the lazy
and shiftless by comparison on this day
in history february 10 1862 a union
naval flotilla which i believe is a boat
with salsa and cheese destroyed the
confederate mosquito fleet in the battle
of elizabeth city in north carolina by
the way how hard is it to beat a fleet
named after an insect you can kill with
a flyswatter
anyway i bet you didn't know i was a
history buff i'm not i just really like
to read wikipedia in the buff which got
me removed from the public library
but that battle like so many that were
waged ensured that 160 years later three
losers could write an article about
emojis back then they had real problems
hell today we have real problems crime
waves inflation covid joe biden but in
the woke world those aren't concerns
emojis are joe rogan is hoop earrings
remember when they were racist it's
problems like emojis and all that other
crap that make academics feel important
and npr look enlightened but in the real
world they don't accomplish a damn thing
it's stupid so stupid i'm giving them a
thumbs down and yeah i'm using the wrong
color and the wrong finger
[Applause]
welcome tonight's guests
when this lawyer approaches the bench
the judges run for cover former acting
attorney general matt whitaker
if he were a cereal he'd be raising kane
fox and friends weekend host will kane
she's like a vintage car
loud shiny and will break down when you
least expect it fox news contributor cat
tim
and the whole nine yards refers to his
inseam my massive sidekick in the nwa
world television champion
tyrus
hey y'all greg
greg i know i'm like i'm the only woman
here again it's like guy's town in here
guys town she doesn't know how he is
guys
you know guy that's an interesting
concept guys town i wonder what guys
town would be like
guy town gambling with your buddies
lifting weights hey beer is cool
watching sports with your friends and
being handsome but it's okay if you're
not handsome goddamn
[Applause]
yeah
thursday it's now gonna be guy town wait
guy town you guys want to see a skit
yeah i forgot about the skit we have a
skit that was supposed to be in the
monologue i couldn't fit it in but it's
a skit you want to see it
cat
yes okay let's see a skit
oh hey stacy just want to say a great
job on that presentation today really
killed it sure it's all thumbs up to you
you're a white man
this is q1
oh hey connor great sales numbers man
keep it up
dude my dad died picking up a hitchhiker
that did that that hitchhiker murdered
him so let's cool it with a thumbs up
oh hey courtney great job at the company
softball game
i am a devoted dog mom all right and
they don't have thumbs so that was
really triggering for me just now okay
okay fine fine fine i'm getting rid of
the thumbs up
and replacing it with these
stick that in your npr tote bags
well there you go it's guy town with
skits
[Laughter]
will last time i checked you were white
uh what color emoji do you use and why
how do you feel about this this analysis
of the emoji issue
i use the yellow emoji yes greg when i
use emojis of course i do
oh see there we go now let me ask you a
question tyrus if you and i were texting
right i don't know it could happen
i don't have your number but maybe one
day if i sent you the white thumbs up
wouldn't you go oh look it will
a little little white pride there
i went out of my way to opt out of the
default yellow emoji to select the white
thumb emoji and that wouldn't raise your
eyebrows
that's a good point i'd do that my
eyebrows would be raised that one dude
was texting emoji to another dude
why is he sending me emojis he could
have just said bye so yeah but you're
right you made a great point because if
i was having a bad day i'd be like this
racist
let me know he's white let me show him
let me find the darkest thumb i can get
you know
it's true they're causing us to
overthink this matt the other thing too
is you know you and i have to share the
same thumb on the phone but you were a
different size they don't have size
options for thumbs they don't have size
options they don't have an option if
i've been in florida for a week
and so there's a lot there's a lot of
complications to the thumb but this
whole story made me want to go for that
green throw up emoji yes because the
story should have been about the
pregnant men emoji
that is also available uh in your
standard keyboard matt apparently you do
not watch this show because we covered
the pregnant man last week didn't we
yeah we're all over that beat yeah yeah
we're we we're we're the first in-depth
it was the whole show it was a whole
show devoted bret bear yeah he came in
he was live on location at the pregnant
emoji man's house
which is actually in the metaverse
riveting yes kat um you are a what are
you
uh
a lot of things yes no but in the age
group you're not you're a jewish
millennial you're a millennial so
when you talk to your millennial friends
what do they say
uh
that is such a
terrible you never seemed older than you
did just now
i think you know what it is i just don't
care about the story hey what are all
the kids in the street exactly
how do you do fellow kids
um yeah we need to all start learning
mandarin because we're done yeah
so we're like i use the white emojis you
do yeah and it's not because i'm
confronting my priv it's just cause like
i know what color i am
which i think you know good for me i
guess i just think that a better
headline for this article would have
been neither i nor anyone i know has a
real problem right like to try to
criticize other people and say this is
what you know
people black people are really worried
about this i'm like is that true i don't
think that's true yeah it's also it's
kind of it's a lot like when you were
talking about uh joe rogan
and it was like this is this is not
something that is like important on your
radar it's but it's something that is
happening in the woke world uh with
white leftists who think that this is
important and and that this needs to be
solved
once again greg i'm the only black guy
on the show
let's roll black guy town
[Laughter]
where where's the sketch that's next
week we're going to do it you don't you
don't know i could be i could be
planning a big black guy town for just
for you
oh well that was about as serious as
this stupid story is first world
problems they're they're getting out of
hand we have so many first world
problems yes we pay no attention to what
we're really going on the fact that this
even made the light of day that somebody
spends time trying to figure out what
thumb
color
to send to somebody else when don't you
usually know the person you're texting
yeah it's not like i just found out do
you think these people are friends the
people that wrote that story have
friends no i i think they literally just
they had a deadline yeah and they got a
thumbs up from their editor or their
boss and they're like oh i hate it so
i'm going to make it racist i think
that's what it was everything
emoji someone who was an emoji
researcher yes
that's not real
that's the other thing like we should we
should spend just one moment ridiculing
the authors
because it took three of them let me be
the contrarian for just one minute okay
sure it could be that these authors are
actually on the cutting edge i have two
sons they spend a lot of time online yes
we're on the verge of the metaverse here
yes then you get to select they play
fortnite your skin they call it their
skin
you can select your
emoji you participate in life in very
soon we're all going to be there or i'm
not going to be but a lot of people are
going to be there cat will be there
you're sick very soon
he says he's not going to be here i'm
not joining the metaverse no i'm saying
the metaverse i'm going to stay in the
real verse what about the thumb when you
like someone's text that's paper white
they didn't even comment about that i'm
worried that they three people didn't
even like look into the real issue here
right that's you know what they needed a
fourth person yep they needed a fourth
person they probably had five but i do
the reverse thing so the thumb is black
when i do it but i've never done it and
a little correction it's avatar
and most of the kids are usually green
blue purple or something that hasn't
been discovered yet with a unicorn horn
so they've completely destroyed you know
my kids do it too so
all right and they have wings lots of
wings yeah i think we really crushed
this topic i this segment today yeah
it's the best segment on fox red bear on
line one yes exactly tell him i'm busy
he always calls he knows when i'm taping
a show
he'll wait up hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else